we lost someone this year who was
beloved around the world and especially
here at comic-con and we wanted to do
something special in his memory
tonight meanwhile in the Batcave someday
she just can't get rid of a bomb always
inspect a jukebox carefully these
machines can be deadly I know you'd
employ your sneezing powder so I took an
anti-allergy pill Oh
[Music]
better put five cents in the meter if
sometimes difficult to think clearly
when you're strapped to a printing press
we've come a long way from the Prime
Minister's exploding cake or happily get
away from Batman that easy
easily easily good grammar is a sensual
government thank you where'd you get a
live fish Batman crimefighter always
carries everything he needs an Asian
tel-aviv Oh
gosh Batman is there anything you don't
know
oh yes Robin several things in fact they
may be drinkers Robin but they're also
human beings to the battery a bat-cycle
to the Batcopter to the Batmobile to the
medicals
I'll do everything I can to rehabilitate
you marry me everything except that
[Applause]